Let's break down this pretty strong new gap campaign. So
gap has a pretty story history of incredible marketing
over the decades.
They've always been savvy and utilizing celebrity
multimedia and culture.
But to compete in 2024 is a legacy brand.
It's quite a different playbook.
And here's what I think
they did well with their Tyler and jungle campaign.
First thing they did well
is they zoned in 100% on their target demographic
with the creative.
It features singer Tyler
and then musical and dance group jungle.
These aren't just some big celebrities
that no one has a real affinity to.
These are really targeted ambassador picks
that are creating collaborative content across mediums
and demographics.
Love that connected the feel of the content
into their lookbooks as well.
Next is assortment.
They're not selling an ambiguous brand or lifestyle.
They're selling specific pieces.
Gap is thinking,
we'll catch on.
This is how product moves today
in revolving
signature themes that can catch on as a look
and then go
big glasses,
material, and style.
They zoned in on linen and their trademark khaki,
which both connects to the brand's history
and is very relevant for the materials
conversation consumers are having right now.
Average consumer is way more educated right now,
and they want linen and cotton
versus materials they don't understand.
This is a zone gap can dominate in their price point.
True, this is just the beginning of gaps new content era,
but it feels really On brand for them
and effective for now.
And I'm curious to see what they do next.